now on to the more important topic of
today
are what I have I learned from taking
this class what are you supposed to
learn what does this class really bring
to you it certainly doesn't bring to to
you a well-defined set of rules that if
you follow those rules a B and C then
you will yet be a successful company
there's no formulas this is unlike many
of your classes which give you
information that if you reliably follow
it you will reliably get a result
business is not that way and so business
is more about unpredictability about
chaos and from being in this class since
1976 I've had a chance to see lots of
people come and go and lots of
presentations like you've seen so far
and from being a student here in this
class I have developed my 15 rules to
simplify what I think I have learned
from this class about the true character
of startup companies the first and most
important rule is there are no magic
rules of thumb perhaps that seem strange
that the first rule says there are no
rules but that is simply the way it is
there's lots of unpredictability lots of
chaos conditions vary your mileage may
vary tuition in pursuing a company in
lots of ways the pursuit of the
entrepreneur I found to be similar to
that of Wiley coyote whoo-hoo as the
practice looked into the acne cookbook
as to how to catch that bird
beat deep but actually he frequently
found himself disappointed in the
results most entrepreneurs fail in fact
several times before they succeed in
fact one of our speakers said that
success isn't an anomaly in a string of
failures the good things happen with
when your failures are small and your
success you say same is true for mr.
coyote a temporary monopoly is the most
important asset to start starting a
company especially if you're an EE or
SES turd you have an opportunity to
create something that no one else has
ever made before and probably doesn't
have the foggiest idea how to do you
have a unique opportunity as a result of
your Stanford experience to create a
monopoly no monopoly lasts forever so
hence a temporary monopoly as up others
try and reproduce what you have done and
eventually with enough time you will
lose part or all of your monopoly but
it's very helpful at first when you're a
small company that you're the only one
in the world that can provide whatever
it is your company provides that ability
to to provide something that's truly
unique helps greatly when it comes time
to try and sell whatever it is large
companies don't like to buy from
individuals or small companies largest
companies will buy from small companies
yet they can't buy it any
other way there are two characteristic
times to start a company I found one
time is more or less straight from
school or soon after school you're young
you don't have a lot of entanglements
you have free time you can start a
company the other kind of company is
formed by people who are almost 50 years
old and have worked for three or four
companies and have considerable
experience and it's something from that
experience that they take as their
secret sauce to help them start a
company they they discover something
that that they see that everyone else is
doing it the wrong way they fix it and
they do it what they think is the right
way and usually they have a bigger more
professional team usually they have more
investment in a larger VC participation
my fifth rule is that business success
may come at the expense of family
success particularly for those who start
a company late in life if you start a
company out of school you probably
aren't married yet and if you are
thinking about being married if it will
all be done at the same time in the
context of a startup company however
those late bloomer entrepreneurs who
start with the wife and kids when
they're almost 50 may have had a long
career where they spent more time paying
attention to their children and more
time at home and when they form a
company they find that the
the obligations of the company are hard
to fulfill and also fulfill all of their
historic family obligations my sixth
rule is that exposure to peer
entrepreneurial experiences is a key
motivational factor for many company
founders it's very hard to be yet in the
middle of Utah and form a high tech
company that's successful there's a lot
of things that go on in the formation of
a company in being in and around other
people who are doing the same thing can
be extremely helpful there are now a
series of groups or companies that call
themselves incubators which are just
large buildings of people comprised of
multiple startup companies who are all
sharing some things with their self
fellow entrepreneurs and also during
their own thing as well so being in and
around company file founders can be very
helpful in trying to start a company
through the years it's been apparent
that differentiation of product stroke
from the competition and clear
definitions of the segments of bit
business or markets that products are
part of are quite important it is
important to have a clear reason why
people should buy what
what it is you have the cell and how
what you have to sell is clearly
different than what other people are
trying to sell founders of successful
companies do not come from any
particular academic standards you may be
a Stanford student good for you you may
have a plus average that's good for you
good for Stanford it doesn't really
predict how successful you're going to
be in for forming a small company it's
not unheard of that a a C student might
be quite successful success in business
does not directly track with your
academic success I think that if it's
not that's prime pricing there are
people who are extremely successful in
in taking and passing tests and doing
school work which someone else can
conceive sup in the signs and something
else to go out on your own and invent
something from scratch successful
entrepreneurs try lots of different
things if this rule is perhaps the most
important role in in my my world of no
rules but what is most important is to
try lots of different things to not be
just stuck in one direction try things
assess how well they work and then
change them
I and change try seven things keep the
best two and then continue you will
never have complete information you will
never know which will be successful so
having the ability to keep multiple
irons in the fire and try experimentally
lots of different things is a key to
success sometimes this even gets into
the technology for for instance is no
real big secret that Google tried
different customer screens with
different people who were you using
their system and that they would do
experiments with their customers to
evaluate which of the men met many
different approaches to a solution they
found the best for their customers it
may be easier to create a good product
when you're also a customer for that
product if you create something that's
that's good you believe for say old
people and you are an old person you may
not have good judgment with regard to
what old people really want if you are
trying to create something for someone
else it's not as easy to optimize as if
it is something that you would like to
own and use yourself hard work and good
ideas are essential but in that many
cases even the best of plans require
luck to make them successful
one of the most difficult things to do
is in attracting customers it's very
important to attract lots of good
customers however lots of people when
they're planning a company do not talk
to customers until very late in the
development cycle this is a big big
mistake you should go out and talk to
customers early and frequently and show
them prototypes and be obnoxious in
working your way in two places where Cup
customers are to get their real-world
feedback talking to customers early is
very important the most frequent reason
why new companies fail is no one wants
what they built they built something
they thought was awesome and no one
wants and why because they didn't talk
to people be cautious about how you
divide up to your company if you have
your five best friends ant and you're
out at the Oasis drinking beer one night
don't form your company's there where
it's formed by five companies each with
an equal one-fifth share it's almost
certain that a company with five equal
founders will fail because you will be
married to those people for a very long
time and the more there are the more
difficult it is perhaps one partner may
be in some rare rare cases two partners
but keep the number of founders small
few successful companies experience
success without setbacks don't expect
your company to rock it up like snapchat
and be worth 35 times your sales after
four years that just doesn't happen and
it won't happen to you it happens to the
other guy this is like in las vegas
where they have a big horn and when
someone wins a slot machine the whole
room knows that there was a slot machine
winner however there are a thousand
other people in that room who didn't win
a slot machine who are watching that's
very similar to the right way the rest
of the world works it will always be
someone else so you cannot count on the
fact that your company is simply going
to be an instant success be prepared for
a bunch of failure before you succeed
the real world is far more sarcastic
than deterministic you've been trained
for years and years and years but there
are things like natural laws on these
law but the Ohm's law if you stick a
voltage on you get a current everyone
does that it works you go into the lab
you test it it works Ohm's law it is
actually not a la it doesn't always work
if you buy a commercial resistor it
works but it if you try lots of things
that can vary in temperature
as you pass current through them no very
in resistance as a function of time and
the current so they'll get hot and when
they get hot the resistance will either
sore or go down there's both kinds the
resistance might go up the resistance
might go down but they definitely don't
follow Ohm's law Ohm's law is a myth
it's an owns owns conjecture Maxwell's
laws also only work in a linear kind of
world in a non-linear world where there
are extreme feels things get weird and
Maxwell's laws need extension why do
founders of startups think they fail
this is a very important chart I'm going
to email everyone in the class of these
slides so don't worry about exactly
these details but there there's a slide
here with which gives you the top 25
reasons top 20 reasons why people think
their recently failed company failed
what is the number one reason it's what
I said low market need what is the
number two reason ran out of cash and
what was the number three reason not the
right team these are important things
and and and I can sit here and say them
is a yeah but it's it's not easy to
apply these rules you have to think
about them all day and all night worried
about everyone forever to succeed in the
company what did the founders get ah
they get equity and you say yeah I like
that part they they get to make a
important company dis
now I think actually as a prior founder
of the company I think that the equity
part doesn't make you feel good for a
long long time being able to make
decisions might make you feel good on a
daily basis because you don't have to
have some one that you don't respect
making the decisions that you don't
agree with you get to make every
decision you want to make but you all
forget if it works pride and
accomplishment of course if it doesn't
work you really really feel bad you
definitely learn more about people and
about the world you become much crappier
and much more aware of what other people
do and think after you form your own
company you get smarter not not smart
perhaps it in the way you have learned
in Stanford EEE classes smart in the way
of the world some of you if you're
successful with your company will become
well known now I personally don't think
that's a good thing I don't want to be
well-known being well-known means that
people bug you and make you a target you
walk around with a target on your back
there's also this kind of question since
today's the second day of the snapchat
experience there's a question well if
you form these companies with lots of
shares how much do you end up with after
going public and I looked all over for
all kinds of information about this top
topic but I discovered
that it varied enormously depending upon
the company who the investors were and
what the history of the company was
after going public however a few years
ago KPMG that's a consulting company did
a detailed analysis of a hundred Silicon
Valley startup companies and they
observed that the sweat equity founders
of the company at the time just after
going public had nineteen percent of the
company that is a lot nineteen percent
of a public company is worth a lot the
rest of the employees had around not
nineteen percent to and the various
investors had sixty-two percent of
course you had just gone public part of
what those investors are is public
investor people but there were lots of
investors involved prior to going public
how risky it is it to start a typical
technology company again this is a chart
which varies all over the place so i
give you my favorite KPMG chart it's all
their fault if you think this is wrong
but essentially they conclude that
twenty twenty percent of startup
companies have above-average returns
whatever that means and sixty percent
have below-average suits returns so
twenty percent are winners sixty percent
are real losers so
I've given you my rules you're empowered
you obviously want to ask me should you
start a company and I see no don't do it
don't start a company you heard me sad
and my answer is yes only if saying no
will not deter you if you're going to do
it sure do it but don't do it because I
say it's a good thing to do it has lots
of problems you're going to suffer I've
had students who have gone out and done
it and failed two or three times come
back just absolutely exhausted broke
they come back to thank me some of them
I was afraid of you know that they might
be a little angry they don't all hit
home runs instantly but somehow they
they all seem to have good spirit I
haven't met an angry one yet but I don't
look forward to the day now you may have
forgotten and I'm just repeating it to
remind you there's was the question of
the monopoly you need a monopoly don't
do it without some sense of what your
monopoly is so the question is how the
heck do you get a monopoly and the
question doesn't have an easy answer and
it's not a question to which i can give
you a simple answer to every new
technology or direction has like this
fog of information and different people
report different things about the same
topic area we have autonomous cars if
you read the papers you would believe
that every
car will be driving itself within three
years well I'll take that but certainly
there will be something in three years
there will be different partial answers
different people will come up with
different approaches probably the
complete problem won't be solved for at
least four years may may be much longer
than that but there are lots of
different approaches to the same problem
but you have to find one and you have to
find your beer direction which is unique
and so it might be coming up in your
mind that can't can we possibly build
something that we don't understand and I
give you a quote from dogbert who said
that nobody would try anything new if
they understood all the consequences
therefore all progress is based upon
faulty assumptions this is very true but
despite that it happens people are
successful but the reasons they're
successful we're not always the exact
reasons that they thought going in
there's lots of new waves of exciting
things coming out biochips cloud apps
nanotech virtual worlds 3d greenhouse
gas the success in each of these areas
will be from being in the right position
when when that wave hits I think you're
going to have a very hard time to try
I can reproduce the successes of the
past by using the techniques of the past
social networks have been done Mark
Zuckerberg solved that problem ah Google
did search try something new find a
different approach or wrinkle and and
then be in in position before that that
approach is viable in his big one of the
problems though is the hot trends vary
with time when I I was a very young
student vacuum tubes were still
important things and I had some very
strong interest in high power vacuum
tubes it was a good thing I was flexible
though when I came to Stanford and I
agreed to look at semiconductors I'm a
semiconductor guy not a high power
vacuum tube guy as a result of the
reality distortion that Stanford gave me
and it was a good thing that I switched
but semiconductors may not be what they
once were vacuum tubes definitely aren't
and even clouds are passe now we have to
get beyond cloud now for each of these
new technologies there is a domain of
information stuff involved social
networks are not the same as
semiconductors there are commonalities
in approaching a high-tech startup
company with all the different
technologies there are commonalities but
there's also differences probably way to
succeed in a high-tech company in a
specific domain is you have to know
the landscape you have to know that the
main rules this is abstract and the
challenge is that the domain rules vary
any character and style for each of the
domains as well so just be aware look at
this slide think about that a little bit
each of these domains fit into some
market segment just because you're doing
a new cloud app doesn't mean you're
going to compete come compete with drug
developers in their new developments
each one of the technologies different
people pursue have different parameters
associated with that different market
sizes different characteristics there's
a whole bunch of data to think about you
should look into all of that for
whatever your choice is because
sometimes you will find that the market
size is not nearly as big historically
is you might have thought it was the
market for wrist wat watches for example
is not economically huge everyone has
one but there are very low-cost device
and they don't don't people don't buy
them yet every year they buy a few in a
lifetime and so the market size for
wrist walk watches which which without
prior thought you might've thought would
be huge is not as as large as you might
like it to be it's also wise when when
you start to have a reasonable financial
goal don't try and be Mark Zuckerberg or
Bill Gates I'm a lot lower than that and
be happy because you're much more likely
to succeed
should you pursue venture capital
funding probably in my experience of
this left many if not most students
coming into the class think that the
most important step to forming a company
dis finding a venture capital list
probably that's not true lots of
successful companies have been formed by
students in this class with no venture
cap capital no angel funding just a few
funds from their parents or Visa card or
something else they they lived lean and
low for a long time and as sixty seated
you're your success with a venture
capitalist will be very dependent upon
exactly how your technology or approach
fits into an existing and current hot
trend if you're in one of these shows
and hot trends perhaps the VC can help
you a lot but for lots of companies vc's
can hurt as much as the VCS are not
always right VCS are right about two out
of ten cuts so of ten groups of startup
companies they let down eight of them
eight of them will will not not have
above-average returns eight of them in
five or ten years may may regret some of
the aspects of their VC experience there
there's lots of secret information about
the performance of
dcs that's very hard to get there's also
some very public information because
some vc's have been invested in by some
pension funds and such and in those
cases the information is published I'm
not going to bore bore you with this I
just put a bunch of scoffing azad but
about VCS and companies if you wish to
look at them all on the slides it's
there with references one important
thing to think about is how much is a
company worth I you start a company
after three years of operation you're
doing almost a million bucks a year in
sales you feel that's an enormous
success how much is that worth and when
do you become a millionaire well it's
very hard to say how much a given
company is worth it's worth exactly what
you can get someone to pay for it there
are things like price/earnings multiples
prices sales multiples but you will find
if you look across different
marketplaces they very radically and
they vary even radically company to
company with in a marketplace some
companies seem to command very high it
now value for their company and some
don't you may have heard all this
information today it may have been a lot
of information in a short period of time
and now the question is how do you start
what what do do you do you have to have
an idea and that idea has to be doable
you have to be able to do
something to work toward that idea you
have to be able to show the idea not in
words but in demonstration to other
people the idea has to be able to be
demo'd most people won't care about your
concept for a company until you have a
demo for that concept the demo able idea
has to somehow have a plan which goes to
a level of business and sales you have
to have a workable plan to go from a
demo to a solution if if your idea is to
create a replacement for gasoline by
making some hot hybrid plant you have to
know how to convert that plant into a
production level of gasoline you even
though that plant may in theory be able
to be converted because the equations or
symbols are right investors are going to
want to know what are the the concrete
steps to convert up a plant or weed in
into gasoline do do you need a pot or do
you need a factory or exactly what do
you need and how much of that has been
demonstrated if you need a to build a
huge weed refinery to turn a plant in
the gasoline that huge weed refinery may
cost millions if not billions of dollars
you'll find it a lot more difficult to
proceed with a workable idea if it takes
such a big investment to get to the next
step
you need to have an idea that serves a
human need like I I have shown you and
told you most companies fail because
their idea doesn't serve a real need of
real customers perhaps it in theory
serves that that need but it's way way
too expensive to have something that
cost 10,000 don't dollars and people
can't afford that price is irrelevant
you'd have to serve a human need it has
to be more than just a technological
seed there's also a different topic I
would just like to briefly a going to
which is about scams you probably are
not not aware of the yet but there is a
whole host of criminals who are looking
to play prey on startup companies
there's all kinds of scams worse than
the Nigerian email scam of what people
out there are trying to do to to defraud
startup companies and I made up this
word fool to help you remember that it
is most important to it first create an
ID in the forecast for what that I idea
becomes that idea has to lead to your
monopoly where you own a space do you
own a marketplace at least for a period
of time there has to be a way for that
that space or idea you you
do you work in two to get out into the
world there has to be an opening to
create a demand sometimes it's obvious
and then sometimes you have to have the
world change a little bit to really
adopt your idea you have have an idea
for a smartphone app but the smartphone
hasn't been built yet that app really
needs to run with so the screen is too
small or there's no way to put the
information on the screen or something
that doesn't fit with today's devices
but it may be a long time before the
devices are available to allow your idea
to prosper and as I said you are going
to fail a bunch of times before you
succeed so you should learn from all of
your failures your failures are not
really failures their educational
experiences education is expensive you
will learn to spend a lot of Education
look for things which can become very
big and not will will peak out at a very
low level I wish you all to have good
good luck but I warn you to be prepared
remember that there's a need for speed
and when in doubt you should fire fire
aim move quickly you will need plant
planning and heart hard work it will
help you make your own luck
remember that you come from a school
with lots of faith famous people who
went out and did things that really did
succeed a bunch of you are going to be
successful not all of you but even those
who succeed they fail a bunch of times
before they succeed thank you
[Applause]